Serena Williams Serena Williams warped
up what could easily have been the last
batch of her career she's won 23 Grand
Slams but is currently ranked outside
the top 600.
the American was up against the world
number two Annette contavite but
produced some trademark shots to make
her Mark in the opening set she
eventually took it on a tie break and
the record crowd of nearly thirty
thousand started to believe
things were a lot quieter though when a
Estonian opponent hit back in the second
set comfortably taking it six games to
two
but somehow Serena found a higher level
in the decider
against a player 14 years her Junior she
showed the fighting Spirit that's
delivered so much success since she
turned Pro as a 14 year old in 1995.
and after two hours 27 minutes on court
she won it 6-2 to progress to round
three
it's the first time in over a year that
Serena has posted back-to-back wins
there's still a little left in me we'll
see the neck we'll see
you know honestly it's you know after I
lost the second set I thought oh my
goodness I got to give my best effort
because this could be it and so um
really I just wanted to just keep trying
and see what I could do and just do my
best and I was just really excited to be
honest
friends without tickets in New York were
able to watch it on big screens outside
happy that the Serena show will go on
for now at least
[Applause]
it was excellent Max excellent match I
am so proud of her she's done it before
and she can do it again and I think
she's really proving to us here that
she's still got it you know this is a
yep a pretty racist country and I think
what was so thrilling about tonight was
all these people
cheering for her thank you thank you
very much
before the tournament not many gave
Serena a chance of winning a record
equaling 24th Grand Slam but now the
perfect Hollywood ending might just be
on the cards
next up she faces the unseated
Australian Isla tamlanovic David Stokes
Al Jazeera